you know blast went from being like la's
best kept secret
um to being the i mean
one of the biggest artists in the
country yeah um you guys just hit number
one on two formats at radio like right
um
kind of take me back to the beginning
though how did you get
involved with blast because like i said
he's been around for like people act
like he's like a new artist but he's
really not yeah he's been around for a
minute i mean me honestly i didn't know
blasphemy like until like 2017 because i
was in college so i went to university
of washington so i moved to seattle and
i'm going to grasp that the huskies yeah
and then i played football there and
then i ended up going to grad school at
southern illinois so i went to illinois
after that i was gone for like six years
a lot of school what were you going to
school for so i got a bachelor's in
journalism advertising and i got a
bachelor's of psychology and then i went
to grad school for pr media development
so
yeah culmination all that and you're
just the one stop shop if i need a
shrink and a pr guy exactly exactly
exactly we pretty much i was doing
like consultations with with independent
artists on teaching them how to monetize
content and teaching them like digital
distribution platforms and how to do it
at what time to do it how to like pretty
much beat the algorithm as an
independent artist so i was charging for
that then i added on the studio services
to that and so um eventually
i met blast and jason cash on the same
day actually shout out to both of them
yeah shout out to both of them so they
both pulled up to the studio with the
actor that played tupac dimitri [ __ ] yep
he should try these [ __ ] yep so [ __ ] he
plays the piano as well so that was
pretty much all just coming up to use
the studio to start making music so i
got introduced to all with
both of those two at the same time and
then really i'll take a look in the
birthday music to be honest with you um
but blast was the one actually
consistently rendering the studio off
for me
and so like you know blast is pretty
much like a man of little words so one
day i just knocked on the door it was
like bro he ran the studio from me like
five times and they said [ __ ] like what
are you doing here right right right so
he playing me music
he played me savage first and i was like
without be noticed before he even knew
beno so played me that played me a
couple other songs played me some videos
so i started asking questions like who
produced it he's like me
and every answer was me every answer was
me from production graphic design
post-production on the video merchandise
whole vision i'm like [ __ ] i'm like but
why are you in the why are you in this
great space like what what is it that
you actually missing and then so we just
started having a conversation and i was
like well this is what i do that's what
i went to school for
i'll do it for free for you just to see
if you like what it is that i'm actually
trying to teach and then if it worked
let's just keep applying it so i just
started off doing like marketing
marketing campaigns rollouts like
hand-to-hand stuff for consumers
um
end up taking over the merchandise and
then we just kept working helping on
videos helping doing creative and then
one day we went to the studio he just
like used to be my manager
like just randomly uh in there was this
prior to the first six tape
yeah yeah so that's all prior to the
first six tape um this is probably like
six months before that
so yeah so i was working with him for a
whole year and some change before i even
became his manager
um so yeah you know just like the
dedication and the day-to-day grind we
was together every day we were starting
to be together every day and it was a
lot of like having a lot of business
conversations um
and it is you know his musical talent
just and then added with our natural
business acumen and like the [ __ ] i went
to school for and studying all that type
of stuff
came together and it was like baking
soda and vinegar